the olympics can make for an exciting
time bringing together people from all
over the globe
identities and communities of all kinds
are center stage
but ahead of the tokyo games the
international swimming federation
also known as fina stood in the way of
one tool to support
representation on july 2nd the
associated press reported that bina had
banned black owned soul cap swimming
caps from use
at competitions a cap designed to
protect natural
longer and thicker black hair from
chemicals in swimming pools
soul cap said it was told by the
federation that the ban was because
the cap does not follow the natural form
of the head
the uk based company responded to the
ban by saying
they had hoped to further their work for
diversity in swimming so swimmers at any
level
don't have to choose between the sport
they love and their hair
alice deering who will be the first
black female swimmer to represent
britain at the olympics
and who first partnered with soul cap in
june 2020
said to sky sports about the band i
don't want little black girls and little
black boys to look at elite swimming and
think it's not
open to them and two-time olympic
medalist leah neal told the new york
times this is so much bigger than
banning a type of cat
neil is a hundred percent correct this
ban without a doubt
further exemplifies the lack of
acceptance in a white dominated sport
while also potentially pushing away many
potential young black swimmers
the winner of multiple olympic medals
simone manuel
has been talking about the struggles
black summers face
for years she opened up to people
magazine last year about how she'd been
laughed at when she told people she was
a swimmer and how others assume she must
play basketball or on track instead
it's very obvious that it's rooted in
thinking that black people can't swim
shouldn't swim or can't be successful in
the sport of swimming
i've gotten laughed at when i've told
people i swim as of july 2nd
fina had said they would review the ban
weeks later
soul cap reported that the organization
had apologized pledging to review its
application process
and offering its full support throughout
the next submission window
in september with a final ruling on the
matter yet to be made
it's clear the people are raising their
voices as the fight for inclusion
and equity continues